Comment on a commencé ce court-métrage ?
Pendant 2 ans tu m'as fait du lobbying pour que j'aille au Japon.
Tu m'as dit "vas au Japon, tu vas kiffer", j'y suis allé.
J'ai kiffé, à peine je reviens t'as fais "t'as kiffé le Japon ?"
T'as fait "Ok, j'ai un projet au Japon".
J'avoue, je l'ai un peu travaillé au corps.
Vous savez, je suis un grand fan du Japon.
Je voulais un projet, où je me dis "je reste plus longtemps
et surtout j'échange avec les gens avec un projet commun."
Et je me suis dit "Un tournage ! Ça parait évident !"
À peine arrivé, on a commencé les repérages
parce qu'on avait que les lieux par photos.
Les décors qui étaient très importants
c'était la maison de Minori
parce que c'est là où se passe la résolution
et aussi l'éditeur
parce que c'est là où ça fait figure officielle
c'est le rêve de Adrien, donc du coup il nous fallait des endroits très précis.
Quand on parlait du tournage à Paris on se disait
"On aura une semaine au début un peu calme".
"On pourra peut-être aller au studio Ghibli".
- Pas du tout.
- Mensonges !
On a repéré le premier jour, le deuxième jour on tournait.
C'était très important pour nous d'avoir un casting japonais.
Oui.
Pour le rôle de Minori, le père de Minori
l'éditeur.
Et donc il y a eu un casting à Tokyo.
Dès qu'on a reçu les auditions
là c'est vraiment... j'ai l'impression de me dire " c'est vrai, le film va exister, c'est sûr".
C'est la première fois qu'on entendait le texte du scénario
en japonais, joué par des japonais.
On a regardé les auditions, on était comme ça "Vas-y passe à la suivante, je veux voir !"
Ça c'était fou !
Le rôle important c'était le rôle de Minori.
Et quand on a trouvé Miharu
- elle était d'elle même...
- Un peu Minori.
Un peu Minori, timide, gentille, volontaire.
Minori est mignonne est gentille je trouve.
Là, on vient de faire la première lecture.
La première fois qu'on entend les répliques dites par toi et par les comédiens.
Je dois diriger en anglais
quelqu'un qui doit lire le texte en japonais.
Cyprien, je lui parle en français
Et lui doit déchiffrer en japonais et avoir l'intonation.
Voilà, c'est fou quoi.
J'ai tout ça à apprendre en japonais, donc je ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez.
Et Louise est en train de se foutre de ma gueule derrière.
Et gros big up à Louise, à l'équipe d'Assemblage
qui est une équipe franco-japonaise
pour la fiction, à Tokyo.
C'était parfait pour nous.
La scène dans l'Izakaya
c'était une des premières scènes de dialogues qu'on a tourné.
C'était tellement bien !
Et y'avait que des acteurs japonais, aucun parlait anglais vraiment.
Santé !
Les figurants, on leur a donné très peu d'indications.
Louise ? Il va parler un peu en français.
Un peu pour lui même, il est bourré.
Et dès qu'ils entendent un mot français qu'ils aiment bien
tout le monde peut le répéter.
"Aurevoir".
"Je t'aime"
Du coup, on était vraiment en train de se dire
on sait pas ce qu'il se passe, mais on est là.
J'ai cherché la chanson en français que tout le monde connait dans le monde
C'est "Aux Champs-Élysées", ils la connaissent !
C'est fou parce que dès que Cyprien est plus dans le plan
on est vraiment dans un film de gangsters.
Avec les salaryman et tout
C'est top !
C'est un peu mon rêve qui se réalise.
Trop content !
C'est marrant parce qu'on a tourné là et après on a mangé là.
Ah oui ! Super moment !
Travail terminé !
Ça fait quatre jours qu'on fait des premières journées.
Et là c'est vraiment une première journée.
Vis ma vie de myope.
Ils sont là-bas.
Ils font des petits gestes pour me dire action, mais je vois rien.
Ok c'est bon !
C'était super d'avoir enfin
ceaucoup de dialogues, de comédies,  d'émotions
dans un décors qui est tellement fou.
La décoratrice qui a fait la petite chambre
de Minori
y'a rien dedans à la base !
C'était des tatamis, c'était vide.
Et il fallait qu'on arrive à comprendre qui est Minori
juste avec le décor.
Elle est dessinatrice, mais elle n'est pas non plus trop kawaii.
Fallait trouver les bonnes références
et elle nous a recouvert la chambre de détail à la Minori
avec des vrais croquis de Tim Fischer.
Ça marche trop bien !
C'est les bonnes couleurs, c'est mignon
c'est chargé en même temps, c'est top !
Imaginons que Adrien il rentre,
Il cherche des trucs, il se met là.
Quand elle le rejoint, elle se met à côté de lui
comme ça vraiment on a un vrai cadre où on voit vraiment ça
maintenant qu'on a la déco
c'était beaucoup plus clair d'être dans ce sens là.
Je crois que ça manquait de dab
quand je me vois en making of en train de
diriger les gens je me dis
"mais comment ils font pour me comprendre ?"
Vous le voyez monter...
Vous le suivez du regard...
...et quand il est en haut...
... dernière réplique.
Ça n'a aucun sens ce que je dis.
C'est probablement mon moment préféré
pour l'instant.
Faire du vélo c'est génial.
Énorme satisfaction de faire du vélo à Tokyo.
Je devais te forcer à dire
"Non mais là t'es en galère !"
Et t'étais tellement en mode
content d'être à Tokyo en vélo
"non mais là t'es sensé être en speed !"
Il faisait tellement beau, avec les cerisiers en fleurs
C'est très compliqué d'avoir
un vélo, taille japonaise et d'avoir quelqu'un dans son dos.
Ça marche ?
Est-ce que c'est dur pour toi ?
Non, c'est ok.
La pochette, fallait trouver un truc.
Est-ce que ça, ça se...
Et sinon si on met la pochette comme ça.
Ça t'aime bien ? On est bon ?
- On a trouvé !
- C'est symbolique.
Les dessins entre vous, qui vous relient, qui vous collent
comme le fromage dans un burger.
Si on va lentement, le skate ne va pas passer vite, pour que je sois stable.
Ok, je vais partir en mode Tokyo Drift, tu vas voir.
Here we go !
Miharu elle me guide, c'est mon GPS.
Je suis chauffeur uBer, également.
Le personnage de Adrien essaie de retrouver Minori
avec ses planches à elle
et ses planches comportent beaucoup de décors.
Donc il se dit
"Peut-être que si je vais visiter ces décors là
je vais la trouver."
Donc du coup il y a cette petite astuce où on voit la case
et on découvre ensuite le vrai décor
et du coup ça le conforte.
Mais pour arriver à ça.
Comment ça se passe ?
Moi je fais un repérage Google Street View.
Mais vraiment je me paume avec mon petit bonhomme, je le déplace.
Je me dis "Ok j'aime bien cet escalier".
Une fois que j'ai trouvé ça, j'envoie à la prod
"Regardez ces lieux-là, Meguro etc."
Eux, au Japon, ils se déplacent
ils prennent les photos
dans différents angles.
Moi sur Photoshop, je fais une fausse planche, pas encore dessinée.
J'envoie le fichier à Tim Fischer, qui est le dessinateur.
Lui, avec ces photos, il a redessiné à l'identique
il a rajouté les personnages à l'intérieur.
Ça a été imprimé et voilà, c'est aussi simple que ça.
C'est tout bête !
Et au final, moi je suis très satisfait du résultat.
Moi ce que je redoutais le plus
c'était les tournages dans la rue
dans les lieux où il y a
littéralement le plus grand nombre de gens au mètre carré.
On aura Cyprien en bas qui va faire une traversée.
On va essayer de le filmer depuis là-haut
ou alors on va le perdre.
Filme bien aussi quand je reviens.
D'accord oui, peut-être, peut-être.
On a tourné dans l'endroit le plus "chaud" de Tokyo
à l'heure où les gens sont les plus fêtards.
Y'a eu 2 ou 3 personnes qui ont fait "Coucou!" devant la caméra.
Et Louise me disait
"Je suis désolée, les gens sont un peu bourrés."
Franchement, ils sont très très calme.
Quand on filme dans la rue
dans le métro, etc.
En fait y'a une telle civilité
- Oui
- que tout le monde se respecte.
"Y'a un tournage on va pas les déranger."
Ça s'est très très bien passé
et on a fait je pense des images que j'adore vraiment.
Le métro à Tokyo, c'est hyper iconique en
fait.
C'est le moyen de transport le plus au point
qui transporte des millions de personnes.
Du coup, on fait honneur au métro japonais qui est très très efficace.
On a beaucoup discuté de notre expérience en tant que français au Japon.
Et c'est ça qu'on a essayé de mettre dans le scénario, c'était de se dire
y'avait l'histoire de base qui est vraiment un passionné de manga
français, qui veut percer au Japon.
Et aussi cette particularité qui est que quand t'es français au Japon
t'es mal élevés sans faire exprès.
De base t'es français
- donc t'es mal élevés pour eux, c'est normal.
- T'es perdant.
Et du coup je trouvais ça rigolo qu'on puisse jouer là dessus
sur cette différence de culture
sur un mec qui veut pas déranger pour
autant, mais qui fait un peu tout à côté.
Grâce aux éditions Kana, j'ai pu parler
du métier de mangaka avec Inio Asano
auteur entre autres de Bonne nuit Pun Pun et Solanin.
Ainsi qu'avec Oono Kousuke
auteur de La voie du tablier.
Je leur ai demandé s'ils pensaient possible,
Pour un français de devenir mangaka au
Japon comme le désir Adrien dans le court-métrage.
De plus en plus de mangakas travaillent en équipe, l'auteur et le dessinateur.
La barrière de la langue peut être un obstacle pour un étranger.
Mais, c'est possible.
Cependant la plupart des mangas dépeignent une sensibilité typiquement japonaise.
Je dois dire que moi-même j'ai parfois du mal à me conformer à ce style.
Si vous désirez devenir un mangaka professionnel au Japon.
Vous devrez apprendre et comprendre ces comportements japonais.
Je pense que publier un manga non-japonais n'est pas si compliqué.
Il y a plusieurs cas de ce type.
Mais, je ne peux pas vous assurer que votre manga ait un succès.
Merci beaucoup !
On avait tous
avec l'équipe image, donc avec Anne-Charlotte et Arthur
envie de capturer le maximum d'image de Tokyo.
Du coup, quand je repense à tout ce séjour là
je me dis mais en fait c'était comme un tournage continu.
C'est ça ! On vivait vraiment le court métrage
on était paumé dans Tokyo.
Et pour moi dans ce projet là, j'ai essayé de mettre des petits objectifs.
Essayer de montrer le Japon, collaborer avec des japonais
et aussi créer un petit voyage avec plein de souvenirs.
On était une petite équipe de sept
français, toutes les cases sont cochées pour moi.
C'était très familial pour moi quoi. C'était au delà de mes espérances quoi.
Moi personnellement, ça m'arrive de voyager, ça m'arrive d'être un touriste
mais je le vis très mal d'être juste un touriste.
Et là le fait de se dire
"Ok on est plus que des touristes, on participe vraiment à cette vie là"
On travaille un peu, on a une vision différente, c'était ça qu'était plaisant, c'était
"Ok ça n'a rien à voir avec juste
le fait d'être là, prendre des photos"
On vivait le truc de l'intérieur avec des vrais
gens.
Merci !
Louise ! C'est pour toi !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner.
Oui voilà, bien sûr !
À sa chaine.
- T'as une chaine ?
- Visiteur du futur, abonnez-vous !
Voilà, c'est ça !